botar do
eu vim aqui falar sobre o movimento e
sobre informação nos treinos do
movimento é uma função vital para toda
as gêmeas mais abordar o o tema da ex
porto que é também assim porque eu acho
que a minha parte das mães cientes são
conquistas coletivas - todas as minhas
são e eu queria fazer que não seja o
conhecimento ao instituto de engenharia
de sistemas e computadores do porto
inesc
achamos que as empresas nunca fui
investidor nunca trabalhei no início
técnica e por isso é que esta história é
mais interessante porque quando eu os
procurei minha empresa para me ajudarem
a desenvolver uma parte importante da
tecnologia no final dessa reunião
disseram que gostaram tanto tem daí que
gostaria de saber que existissem empresa
e que entram site nesse conhecimento de
graça e poderia acompanhar um centro
para equipamentos nos maus momentos e é
muito bom ver o ministro quer que trai o
movimento goleiro e foi dita que o
acerto é tão natural como respirar no
chão duas coisas que nós não temos uma
noção consciência é isso é importante um
vídeo é para nos lembrar do movimento
nas nossas vidas ao longo da nossa
estratégia
espantoso não é
as memórias mais fortes temos nas nossas
vidas estão todas relacionadas com o
movimento é é absolutamente fascinante
aquilo que nós conseguimos ver do
movimento de alta ganhou ou de uma da
linguagem corporal conseguir perceber
muita coisa de uma thurman um beijo de
uma forma de andar e isso é um bom amigo
ensino
será que é possível construir é para
eles conseguissem as trilhas informação
interpretá la girar colocar nela então
fui existem mata dos dispositivos
fantásticos dentro do laboratório
no flat em eu não consegue ouvir os
movimentos do dia a dia
existem outras tecnologias muito básicas
que medem a atividade
então existem outras que têm um capital
há muitas delas hoje existem muitas
coisas de uma forma que nem vou tentar
detectar por exemplo a qualidade do sono
através do movimento de um prazo e uma
oportunidade
achei que havia uma lacuna é mais que
isso é ambição era um em cada serviço
será possível construir para eles que
extraiu o mesmo conhecimento dos nossos
sentidos está em movimento e assim em
2006 no livro um protótipo desenvolvido
na faculdade de engenharia foram os
investigadores têm um novo clube é é
natasha é a forma de andar a enganar as
pessoas
é este projeto
para vocês terem uma ideia do que se
pode fazer com a informação e formação
do movimento mubarak um exemplo muito
trivial como utilizar nos planos um
dispositivo para é utilizar a informação
do movimento obenasa de pacientes
acamados para aumentar e é e ciência e
da informática
eu adoro a atividade mas a minha mulher
decidiu equipar o os enfermeiros são os
recursos mais escassos três hospitais
dos lados e equilíbrio com um século 21
pouca tecnologia tenha sido desenvolvida
para os ajudar
é eu gostei muito rapidamente como
formação muito incompleta é muitas vezes
sabendo que não ter uma má decisão mas
mesmo assim é melhor precisa nenhuma e
nada existe para os ajudar e ocupa muito
tempo sem flyer e que é muito proveitoso
muito confortável para o paciente era o
corpo do instrumento dos pacientes
acamados
alguns porque são idosos e tem risco de
ter desenvolver úlceras ou os caras
outros porque têm problemas
respiratórios o tempo sua companhia na
posição errada pode ter problemas ou
problemas carneiros
como é que fazes hoje todos os pacientes
numa rotina para evitar falhas e isso dá
um trabalho que chega aos enfermeiros
que têm campos de ensinar pessoas que
não precisam ser posicionado porque
alguns têm capacidade de se mover
outros têm capacidade de se mover mas
estão sob o efeito de sedativos denúncia
nova naturalmente e
é pra outro lado profissional pacientes
que estavam a dormir e que não querem
ser incomodados porque têm as suas
atividades normais e o que nós fizemos
foi um simples dispositivo que não
utiliza o movimento dos pacientes podem
ser 10 saem mil e não vários edifícios e
passeios por 15 10 porte pode ser visto
não tablet a um smartphone que lhes
permite aos enfermeiros saber que está a
mexer bem carlos fábio chegou em anos
vindo assim o seu o seu o seu trabalho e
deixando incomodar os churros pacientes
estão o colchão eficiência
há uma parte que nos interessa é ainda
muito mais aquilo que distingue é a
primeira grande instituição do ser
humano em relação aos outros animais é é
um começar um livro arte entre pontes
acredita que com essa intenção de
consumo muito menos energia quando 44 -
libertou um conjunto que a cirurgia foi
usurpada conserva para fazer a segunda
grande destruição do ser humano em
relação aos outros animais que foi ter
racionalidade ou seja a única parte nada
para estar em contato com o cel
isso é um fantástico porque são
repositórios de informação de tudo o que
nós fazemos com o nosso corpo
eu me inclino isso tem um reflexo nos
pés e e então nós seguimos bicadas a
tentar extrair da informação nos pés
particularmente é que o que é chamado é
preciso plantar ou seja a distribuição
no pé e na planta do pé quando pousa
quando pousou no chão longo desse
percurso como chan
isso é único é um cada um de nós tem uma
forma de enfrentar um carro com as
nossas opções digitais
o porto não está ainda muito mais
mas é interessante porque quando há uma
alteração consiste do padrão da marcha e
se normalmente é um indicativo é um
indicador de que existe um problema
físico ou um problema neurológico
imagine que os vossos sapatos ou 200 e
conseguem e de tarot essa alteração do
padrão e que 200 deputados
o alzheimer é detectável dez anos mais
cheia do copo seria de como seria normal
se consegue imaginar a é qualidade de
vida com que ele e mais três anos por
ter sido detectada esta doença uma fase
muito por causa disto é que o pode ser
conseguido através da informação dos
dois pés
eu vou mostrar um pequeno vídeo também
com o dispositivo 9 nós é que permite
ver 11 um paciente com avc que posiciona
o 1º open afetado primeiro pela porta da
frente e por trás disso tem lei energia
consome mandaram e e que esta gente
consome para conseguir tentará nada
normalmente depois da forma correta e
com isso poupar em conjunto de problemas
que seja é falta de confiança inarus
aqui e inclusive melhorar sua
performance
uma das coisas que nós também
descobrimos é que isso funciona ao
contrário ou seja nós temos alguma
alteração na forma andares tem efeitos
físicos têm efeitos físicos e tem frente
e neurológico e e é isso ainda mais
fantástico e uma das coisas que nós
pensamos logo para poder usar é esta
essa informação seria expor e uma das
coisas que então se á nos 11 1
uma instituição uma organização daqui do
porto é velho fracções que não é treino
11 atletas profissionais e criativos e
fomos extrair informação que era
necessário para a corrida por duas
pessoas que queiram fazer sua atividade
física seja é correr uma das coisas que
descobrimos é que existem imensos
dispositivos para manter o hábito
intervir na mira é o ritmo da corrida é
um conjunto um conjunto incrível as
coisas não existe nada para avaliar é
técnica do condor saber como é que
ocorreu como é que ocorreu então
seguimos fazer um dispositivo simples e
tomar esta tecnologia silva todos para é
avaliar a técnica é desses corredores é
e dando a possibilidade do canal de
informação que até agora só os dois
deles de forma a melhorar a sua prática
na índia nas suas performances
a gente gosta de competir também em 1
ao mesmo tempo evitar divisões que nós
temos conseguido fazer com essa
exploração é um do da informação do
movimento que eu escolhi presta é é
difícil sou capaz do porto e cria
francisco repare deixou capazes do norte
tivessem ganho corridas então só screen
mulheres aurora cunha e sá fernandes
realça a nota
não sei se quer dizer que aqui no norte
só há alguma coisa hoje só nós é que
somos daltônicos e na piscina não teve
os orgasmos múltiplos
obrigado